nazira et joséphine abied habite le
quartier du port de beyrouth
elles étaient présentes le jour de
l'explosion qui a fait au moins 171
morts et 6000 blessés
une journée que nazira n'oubliera jamais
pendant l'explosion j'étais assise ici
sur ce canapé et nous mangions des pois
chiches
regardez le sang sur la fenêtre j'ai
seulement entendu une explosion et une
voix qui a explosé dans mon esprit et
dans mon coeur puis joséphine était
assise ici et a vu la fenêtre tomber
vers moi si leur maison a été grandement
endommagés elles ont également été
touché au visage mes yeux et ma tête ont
été touchés par l'explosion mais avec le
temps je me sens mieux
malgré le chaos elles ont quand même pu
apporter leur aide aux personnes dans le
besoin
le jour où cette catastrophe s'est
produite
il n'y avait pas d'hôpital pour recevoir
un patient une femme est restée avec moi
pendant 12 heures et à appeler un
hôpital qui lui a répondu qu'il ne
pouvait recevoir personne je me sens
malade pauvres et fatigué depuis le jour
de ma naissance
j'ai servi et aider tout le monde comme
si c'était ma famille et mes enfants
une semaine après l'explosion nazaire à
et joséphine abiad continue de rénover
leurs maisons endommagées par l'une des
pires catastrophes qui conduit le liban